what I love most about using conmigo is
it gives me the agency as a teacher to
be able to kind of set parameters for my
classroom while still giving my students
exposure to the AI that's going to be a
huge part of the world that they're
heading towards after they graduate we
know this is going to be a part of their
lives we want them to have exposure to
these tools but we do want to make sure
they're also getting used with Fidelity
that our classroom assignment aren't
getting negatively impacted through the
integration of AI doing you know too
much for them and kigo does an excellent
job of setting boundaries for those
students so they can still engage and
have those resources but in a more
tailored educational setting I'm
department chair of a very busy English
Department with a lot of course
offerings and one of the struggles that
we had as we branched out into new
curriculum was making rubrics and having
the time to make these really effective
pieces what I loved most about my time
with kigo was that create a rubric tool
I loved how interactive it was because I
was able to take our actual unit plans
and the goals that were written in those
unit plans and create a rubric from
scratch with conmigo going back and
forth articulating exactly what I wanted
and it was able to take a lot of the
strain off of the amount of time that it
would take to draft a rubric that is
complex that has different levels
constructive feedback in it and it made
that process that normally would take me
about an hour no more than 15 minutes
using kigo is absolutely an excellent
starting point for teachers that don't
know a lot about AI if they're wanting
to get that practice with their students
and especially if they're wanting their
students to be able to get used to
asking the exact question they're
looking for the answer to that's a big
challenge for our students that kigo
meets very well for new teachers who
have not been in the classroom before or
if they're running into a situation
where they have a new prep this year
that they haven't had in the past the
thing that kigo does that can be very
helpful for them is it really helps on
that lesson planning side when it comes
to all of the steps that are involved
with a first time with a a prep or
content area we know that so much leg
work goes into creating worksheets
creating assignments creating these
lesson plans that we would then use for
years to come and modify but that first
year takes so much time and energy and I
really believe that kmo will be helpful
for new teachers or teachers that are
again in a new prep it'll really make it
easier for them to use their planning
time in a more streamlined way the
refresh my knowledge tool in particular
particular is very helpful for a teacher
that is starting a new content area or a
new grade level maybe they need a
refresher on a particular reading that
they haven't taught in a long time or a
particular subsection of a different
science field uh it will go through the
different parts of that concept and kind
of break it down in a way that would you
know give the teacher kind of that
background that they need without them
having to go to a bunch of different
platforms to find what they're looking
for as a teacher I think the thing that
I appreciate most about conmigo is the
fact that it takes a lot of the
shoveling that is involved with being a
teacher out of the way that heavyduty
leg work of
drafting a a rubric drafting a lesson
plan building that email that you're
going to send out to all of your parents
to notify them about a novel you're
about to
teach because it can help me with that
initial step in the process my plan time
is able to be used more effectively on
all fronts I can give students more
tailored feedback I can attend more
one-on-one conferences with my kids I
can have more of that face-to-face
interaction that brought me into the
profession to begin with no one signs up
for teaching because they love writing
rubrics no one signs up for teaching
because they love writing a lesson plan
and putting all the stand in there they
sign up for it because they love
children and they love working with kids
and helping them grow so more of my time
can now be spent doing what I love which
is working with my
kids